[Musique]
michel et pablo ont deux enfants nathan
est florence mais rien ne va plus entre
eux et se séparent et se partagent la
garde des enfants avant leur séparation
ils recevaient du gouvernement agrément
de soutien aux enfants
depuis qu'ils se partagent la garde
chacun a donc droit à sa part moitié
moitié
michel avise le gouvernement du
changement et le manque de recevoir sa
part mais pablo lui oublie de le faire
la mémoire lui revient trois ans plus
tard il se rue sur le téléphone et
demande à recevoir trois ans de paiement
rétroactif mais non il aurait dû y
penser bien avant car il n'a droit qu'au
11 derniers mois
la loi est stricte pas de pitié pour
ceux qui oublient même si le soutien
pour nathan rées florence a diminué de
moitié depuis trois ans l'autre moitié
est perdu sauf pour les onze derniers
mois
le fin mot de l'histoire pour le soutien
aux enfants pensez à faire vous de voir